so Airbnb some interesting things are
going on so Airbnb you know very well is
awesome company one of the sort of most
successful startups of the last decade
or so and was about to go public this
year and was preparing for it and now
with coronavirus you know travel has
stopped hospitality you know hotels
casinos they're all taking a total
beating and Airbnb of course is gonna
get caught up in the crossfire as well
and so a couple interesting things here
so Airbnb financially you know their
revenue must have dropped by fifty sixty
seventy eighty percent essentially
overnight and with an indefinite time
span we don't know how long this is
gonna last the second thing is Airbnb
not only does have a huge you know staff
on payroll and now revenue drops but all
the hosts were essentially small small
small entrepreneurs so some people did
you know a traditional thing they just
rented out an extra bedroom in their
house but a lot of people once they got
a taste of that money they started
buying places renting out places and
subleasing and basically putting it on
air and bebe and so all those people now
there's this thing that was a moneymaker
for a couple of years has gone to zero
and so I think there's something very
interesting that's gonna happen where
what happens to all these hosts who got
places just to Airbnb them and now the
Airbnb income has sort of totally dried
up are they gonna default on their
mortgages are they gonna default on the
rent payments if they're if they're
subleasing or are they gonna turn into
just normal rentals I don't know what's
gonna happen but what about all this so
you already know what's going on in
Zillow you're the one who told me right
well I did see some charts yes so I saw
some charts that basically showed on
Zillow normal housing so just normal
rentals not a short-term Airbnb stay but
just here's an apartment for lease for
six months is exploding so like it looks
like the coronavirus it's like here's
last month one little blue dot this
month fifteen blue dots on the map right
it's like the number of listings is
exploding for rentals which is also bad
for Airbnb because in places like San
Francisco where there's a house
shortage and four years Airbnb has been
saying oh we don't contribute to the
housing shortage we are we're a
different thing altogether
well now it's actually kind of a whether
it's whether it's truly the the proof or
not I don't know but it certainly does
look like if you're somebody who was
anti air B&B you have a lot of evidence
a lot of ammunition now to say hey look
when we turned air B&B off look at how
much more housing supply came on the
market look how that lowers rents for
everybody well you know what Airbnb is
doing now though is long-term rentals
they've been getting into that for a
while where you could rent something for
many months maybe many years and that
part is growing so it's growing a lot
right now
right so I'm curious whether people in
cities who are anti Airbnb are gonna
take this and run with it and yes yes
very sensitive to legislation right they
changed some rules here in San Francisco
where it's like you can only do 90 days
out of the year and you have to live in
the place you have to prove that blah
blah blah and that you know eliminated
like 30 or 40 percent of the listings
overnight when that legislation happened
to your or to ago so now I wonder if
it's gonna get worse
sander you know sander I'm googling them
right now you know them know oh that's
the like it's the hotel or explain
saunder it's basically if you are
traveling for work and you want to go
stay somewhere you'll stay at asan der
often let's see I'll go to sander comm
it's also if you want to stay somewhere
for like three months like let's say
you're going somewhere for three months
and you want to and you have to make a
lot of money in order to do this it's
high-end [__] like in San Francisco it's
like five or six grand a month need a
place to stay or work we know it's time
here the better yeah the best parts of
home and hotel so it's like a it's like
a an apartment that you can rent for two
months
right so the upper housing but done well
yes but they just laid off 20% of their
company it looks like wow yeah today so
I think that's gonna be very interesting
how these different companies get
affected you know I'm rooting for Airbnb
I think it's a great product I think
it's a great company I hope that they
have you know a war chest of cash that
lets them endure this time but
you know we'll see it's a keeping an eye
on it if you could invest a little bit
of what you can you can go and buy
secondary shares if you're gonna invest
money at Airbnb z-- previous valuation I
think they raised money on a thirty
billion dollar valuation would you
invest in that right now what I need to
know more right I need to know about the
how the company's financials look and
let's say that revenue drivers people
let's say revenue dropped 70 percent for
this I'm not so concerned about the 70
percent drop because that's that I think
is is more temporary so I just need to
know do they have enough cash in the
bank to endure this or that that's three
billion dollars okay so you've got three
billion dollars you know they're
probably burning several million a month
but like okay three billion should still
last you through this time and then the
other question is where the fundamentals
good to begin with so a lot of times
these companies don't have great unit
economics or fundamentals to begin with
and so when the downturn comes and
people start looking for things that are
more stable more sure bets these
high-growth but poor unit economic
companies they struggle they were
profitable in 2018 this is like a
analysts call again I think they're also
profitable in 2019 this is all public
information right so yeah so if they're
public if they're profitable right now
even with this explosive growth and yeah
it's probably a pretty good bet to pick
up a little secondary there
[Music]